you yes you you are a bigot are you a
straight man who only wants to have sex
with women are you a gay man who only
wants to have sex with men are you a
bisexual man who wants to have sex with
people of both sexes but only if they're
good-looking are you asexual you're a
bigot
according to Samantha Allen of The Daily
Beast it is quote deeply disappointing
but unsurprising that under 20% of
Americans in a recent survey said they
would be open to having sex with a
transgender person that's because she
says quote cultural acceptance has
tended to lag behind formal recognition
it turns out that according to the left
all sexual behavior is malleable and
based largely on social structures that
have been implemented by the patriarchy
men and women don't exist but for their
self perception we know that a man can
be a woman and a woman can be a man
regardless of biology
that's why caitlyn jenner isn't just a
man with a mental disorder and some
plastic surgery and hormone injections
Caitlyn Jenner is as much of a woman as
Michelle Obama the left reasons that if
a man can be a woman that a man who only
wants to have sex with biological women
must be a bigot his desires have been
wrongly defined by a society that
restricted the definition of womanhood -
you know like women if only men had been
exposed to the deeper truth of gender
early if only they'd known that some
women have male genitalia then perhaps
they'd be willing to have sex with
biological men who are actually women
the same is true with regard to
homosexuals of course if a woman is a
lesbian it's discriminatory of her do
not want to have sex with a man who
identifies as a woman her desires have
also been shaped by her environment and
her environment has run a stark but
wrong however so wrong contrast between
biological men and biological women if
all of this sounds insane that's because
it's totally crazy straight men are
attracted to women not men who identify
as women straight women are attracted to
biological men as a general rule
homosexuals are attracted to members of
the same biological sex
attempting to pretend to a reality does
not change that reality but the left is
plagued by two myths that lie in direct
opposition to one another the first all
human behavior can be changed by
changing society at large the second all
human behavior is innate and unchanging
under the first myth if we just train
people than men and women are the same
and that even their genitals don't
provide a meaningful difference men will
begin having sex with transgender women
and women will begin having sex with
friends gender men under the second myth
however transgender identity itself is
immutable
changing as is homosexuality and
heterosexuality this provides an
unanswerable conundrum for transgender
advocates how can they get people to
accept transgender people sexually when
people's sexuality is supposedly
unchanging so the left merely ignores
the problem in papers it over with the
word bigot reality isn't bigotry people
are attracted to people they're
attracted to there is a biological
component to that as well as a cultural
component but ignoring biology in favor
of culture is idiotic and ignoring
culture in favor of biology is ignorant
they both play a part the suggestion
that discriminatory nastiness is at the
root of perfectly logical biological
desire for people to have sex with
members of the opposite biological sex
is merely a slur a crutch to cover up
the illogic of the far-left when it
comes to both gender and sex i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
Oh lots to get to today we're gonna go
through the Trump budget we are also
going to go through the left bizarre
views with regard to terrorism but
before we do any of that first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
tracker so do you lose stuff a lot I
lose stuff a lot as people in our office
can tell you I often lose equipment when
I'm on the road I wouldn't have if I'd
put a tracker on that so at home I put a
tracker on my keys I put a tracker on my
wallet I put a tracker on my phone and
by doing that it makes sure that I never
lose any of these things my wife's phone
always falls asleep or dies and we never
know where it is that's why there's a
tracker on the thing so we can find it
the way that it works like a coin sized
device and you put it right there on the
keys on the phone on the wallet and then
you can use your phone or you can use
your keys to hunt down your phone you
just hit the button and boom you
suddenly get the noise and it locates
the the phone wallet or keys for you if
the zombie apocalypse is here and you
don't know where you put the chainsaw
well you should have put a tracker on
the chainsaw you're never gonna have to
worry about losing things again thanks
to tracker comm so you go to tracker
comm its tra ckr comm track our comm and
for that promo code been receive $29.99
off any purchase of two or more devices
that's the tracker comm the tracker comm
promo code Ben and if you used that
promo code Ben again you get $29.99 off
any purchase of two or more devices and
as I say it saved my marriage because my
wife and I lose stuff all the time
also if you try to track her out with
our 30-day money-back guarantee you can
find out what you've been missing so if
you don't like it then you get your
money back as well so there's no risk to
you again tracker DICOM use that promo
code ben's they know that we sent you as
well okay so there's one more fallout
from this terrorist attack that happened
in Manchester and I guess it was Monday
evening and the left continues to
demonstrate why it is that nobody will
trust them with national security first
off it is important to note the
background of the attacker here it turns
out the attacker may have had links
directly to terrorist groups they've now
arrested I guess for people who are
involved in this terror cell so the idea
that this was another one when these
lone Wolf's you can never see it coming
this guy had been had been on the radar
of the police always there red flags
this guy been on the radar of the police
for years according to the BBC a bunch
of
had actually called him in to the police
because of his views and because he and
his friends were expressing craziness a
while ago and the police just didn't see
it coming and now there are 22 people
dead including an 8 year old girl a 14
year old girl it's just horrific all the
way through and there were people in
Britain who are concerned there may be
another terror attack they went on
critical alert yesterday which means
that they felt that another terror
attack was imminent Teresa may is the
Prime Minister of Britain she came out
and she said that yesterday it has now
concluded on the basis of today's
investigations that the threat level
should be increased for the time being
from severe to critical this means that
their assessment is not only that an
attack remains highly likely but that a
further attack may be imminent I mean
that's scary stuff obviously and the
fact that all of these the fact that all
these people on the Left don't
understand in basic terms why there is
concern about the rise of Muslim
immigration into unvetted Muslim
immigration into states like Britain is
just asinine you know when when the
Mayor of London who's a Muslim guy when
he says that people just need to get
used to terror attacks look the fact is
that there are some terror attacks that
are going to be non preventable there
there will be there will be some terror
attacks they're not preventable in the
same way that some school shootings are
not preventable but it is also true that
those terror attacks are not all terror
attacks and this one was clearly
preventable you had what looks very much
like a terror cell operating in the
centre of Britain and it is a fact that
as your unvetted muslim population goes
up in a country so does your rate of
terror attack this has been true in
france it's been true in germany it's
been true in sweden it's been true in
Britain you know pretending that the
culture of the populations that you
intake has nothing to do with the with
the activities of those populations is
just silly all around now naturally the
left has found its enemies and enemies
are the right so you know they know
exactly who to blame the this Democratic
senator of Chris Murphy who is from
Connecticut I believe he came out
yesterday and he said that the real
problem here obviously is Donald Trump I
mean if we're really gonna worry about
about the the possibility of terrorists
had clearly President Trump is to blame
for some odd reason that he can't
explain
and so many of us are worried about some
of the rhetoric of the Trump
administration because we worry that
that combined with robust online
recruitment might end up in an attack
like this happening in the United States
okay the idea that if Trump goes out
there and says things that Muslims in
the United States are gonna join terror
groups is just asinine it's just really
silly the fact is the people who go out
and commit acts of terror our people who
are deeply ensconced in a religious
worldview that does not care whether
Obama is President or whether Trump is
president as we know worldwide terror
rose dramatically when President Obama
was president is it because terrorists
liked Obama less than they liked bush of
course not they hated george w bush they
thought george w bush was a cowboy they
thought that he was a crazy texan cowboy
christian guy and supposedly obama was
gonna smooth those those details over
remember you remember how obama went on
his apology tour ii went to cairo and
talked about how the Western world was
largely responsible for all of this evil
and the Muslim population well they they
couldn't be blamed if they were really
radicalized because after all the West
had done all of these terrible things
and then he proceeded to allow radical
Muslims to take over a bunch of
countries and lo and behold the terror
rates increased so it really has very
little to do with what America says it
has much more to do with how many
terrorists we allow to live but again
the left is living in this imagined
world this this John Lennon imagined
world where it's religion and and borers
that's really the problem everybody deep
down wants the same thing absolute
nonsense everybody deep down does not
want the same thing some people have a
religious devotion to murder other
people Katy Perry is the latest example
of this so Katy Perry this video is no
longer available apparently apparently
she took it down but yesterday there was
a video of Katy Perry talking with some
talk-show host about the Manchester
Massacre and here's what she had to say
I think that the greatest thing we can
do is just unite and love on each other
and like no barriers no borders like it
we all need to just coexist ok it's very
hard to coexist as people who wanna
murder you so some people were saying
she was saying this about the fan base
between Ariana Grande's fan base - this
happened ariana grande concert and Katy
Perry's fan base ok first of all if your
chief concern and
aftermath of a terrorist attack is the
is the coming together of two pop star
fan bases I'm gonna go with your
slightly myopic if she means that the
entire world needs to have no borders no
barriers katy perry owns a ninety
million dollar house in los angeles with
a giant barrier all around it why
because she can't even trust the
paparazzi not to come into her yard let
alone islamic extremist so the idea that
that we can all just get together and be
friends and if we're just kinder and
gentler to one another that if we just
live our lives and be nice to one
another this is gonna fix things it's
actually sort of disrespectful to
islamic terrorists what i mean by that
is they don't deserve respect obviously
but it's implying that they're just a
bunch of vacillating dweebs who will
just switch away from islamic terrorism
the minute that warm isis i'm like if
we'd offer them free ariana grande
tickets then maybe they wouldn't bomb
the place okay this is just silliness
obviously there is a mode of thought
that suggests the west is evil and needs
to be destroyed mark Stein has a really
good piece on this today over its stein
online where he talks about the fact
that you are seeing the the west begin
to crawl into its turtle shell in an
attempt to avoid pissing off some of the
worst people on earth so you remember
when Charlie Hebdo is attacked right
before Charlie Hebdo was attacked there
were a bunch of people in the West who
said it was terrible the Charlie Hebdo
was making fun of radical Muslims now I
disagreed with some of the material in
Charlie Hebdo but they have every right
to do that and it's good that
publications like Charlie Hebdo exist
even though I really disagreed with it
you know the same thing is true with
ariana grande we here on the program
we've deconstructed culture with ariana
grande I don't like a lot of the
messages of her songs I think that she's
contributing to a pop culture that isn't
very good but that said I'm glad that
people like ariana grande are allowed to
perform however people like ariana
grande want to perform you know if
parents think that rehearse that her
shtick is not appropriate for their kids
I'm an agreement but that's not the same
thing as what the Islamic radicals would
do which is create a society where
Ariana Grande it was not allowed to do
any of these things where they would
restrict by governmental Fiat all of
this where they would whip ariana grande
beat ariana grande kill the people who
listen to ariana grande this idea that
we can all coexist that bumper sticker
is the dumbest bumper sticker in the
world it's such a dumb bumper sticker
because the fact is that only some of
the people on that bumper sticker
actually wish to coexist
other
people's on that bumper sticker wish not
to coexist okay there's a Jewish star on
the coexist bumper sticker and there's
an Islamic crescent on the bumper
sticker
okay the 1.2 million Muslims living
inside Israel they're Muslim MKS living
inside Israel members of Knesset living
inside Israel there's a Muslim Supreme
Court judge inside is ruling two of them
now you know the fact is that there are
zero Jews living in Saudi Arabia and
they barred Israeli Jewish journalist
from even coming into the country is
that coexistence now the idea that the
judeo-christian society is in just a
question of coexistence with the Islamic
radicals is absolutely asinine and it's
also asinine to pretend that there very
few of these people because the fact is
there may be very few people who are
willing to commit terror there are a
hell of a lot of people who are willing
to cheer them on and that's a very
frightening prospect with which we ought
to that we ought to take certainly very
seriously it's it's such a it's it's
such foolishness and again this is why
people don't trust so remember Katy
Perry you know was the person who was
stumping for Hillary Clinton Katy Perry
was an acolyte of Hillary Clinton's Katy
Perry was somebody who was out there
pushing for Hillary Clinton for
President of the United States wearing
the Obama dress wearing the Hillary
Clinton dress she is considered a
respected voice in the left-wing
movement that voice that's not somebody
you're going to trust with with national
security and that's why really that's
why you know you saw that Rasmussen is
reporting that Trump's approval ratings
have bumped back up to 40 48% never
asked me since usually a little bit of
an outlier in terms of approval ratings
but Trump's approval ratings have
increased that's for a couple of reasons
one he went on this warm trip and he's
not making any big boo-boos
he really isn't you know we can make fun
of the sword dance and the touching of
the glowing orb in Saudi Arabia and all
of this but Trump really has avoided a
lot of big boo boos which is good for
him also there was a massive terror
attack and when there's a massive terror
attack people want somebody in charge
who wants to kill the people who want to
perpetrate the terror attack it's that
simple
Trump's approval rating has bumped
because people are not focused on the
Trump brush' stuff they're focused on
the terror attack and they're focused on
the fact that he's out of the country
and Trump isn't using Twitter to
distract them now this I think proves
the case that we have been making here
on the bench Shapiro show for a long
time which is Trump could be successful
if he could control himself stop with
the trigger craziness and just pursue
policy you know that I hope that this
foreign trip is actually a wake-up call
to President Trump if he does more of
this than he'll be just fine
so again the world is what the world is
and for all of the foibles the President
Trump has pursued when President Trump
says he wants to kill as many terrorists
as possible and treat them as the evil
losers that they are I think most people
resonate to that now I do want to talk
about the the democratic narrative
regarding Trump Russia collusion totally
falling apart but before I do that I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at blink cast so I love bling cast
okay this is a new app that you download
to your phone and it is just fantastic
what is it well bling cast helps you
read all of these books without actually
having to read all of the books you look
at what they call blinks you have all of
this stuff to do you have 15 minutes in
the car and you don't really want to
listen to 500 pages of a novel you don't
wanna listen to 500 pages of a business
book you actually just want to get the
main points that's what blinken's does
it boils down all of these large books
to smaller points so that you can digest
them the blinka staff has over 2,000 of
the best-selling non-fiction books
transforms into packs that you can read
or listen to in just 15 minutes what's
fantastic about that is that I've read a
lot of the books on these on these lists
but it's 500 pages and all you come up
with
after reading 500 pages is the basic
points anyway so you may as well just
read the blankets or you may listen to
the blankets in your car and then you
get all of the main points anyway I mean
they they have the book on there by the
way why nations fail right terrific book
about national development and why
nations collapse when why nations fail
is not only a terrific book it's also on
blankets so that means that you don't
have to wade through those 500 pages
what I remember about why nations fail
could probably be boiled down into 15
minutes and so instead of having to read
the whole book and then try to remember
the 15 minutes worth of content that you
remember you just go to blankets and
they'll give you the 15 minutes of
content that are the most important if
you're just reading these books if
you're lucky maybe you'll get through
one book a week but with the blankest
app you can get through two or three
books on your way home you just learn
and learn and learn if you're addicted
to information away I am blink astiz the
place for you they have a special offer
just for our audience if you go to blink
accom slash Ben right now if you go to
blink ascom slash Ben then you will get
your free trial you got three months off
your yearly plan if you join today so
you get a free trial so you can try it
out or if you join you get a three free
months off your yearly plan it's be Li
NK ist
Linkous comm / bends to start that free
trial bling cast calm / then again they
take all of these books and they boil
them down into power packs that you can
digest on your ride home
terrific app again use that / fun to let
them know that we sent you as well okay
so while Trump is abroad this has been a
much better week for president Trump the
last three weeks in a row were s for
president Trump this one has been much
closer to an A for president Trump and
part of that is because the Democrats
are still struggling to come up with
this Trump collusion narrative that
works and they're having a tough time
with it so John Brennan he's a former
CIA director under President Obama he
was the CIA director all the way up to
January 20th and he is called to the
hill to testify in front of the House
Intelligence Committee about the leaks
and about the Trump Russia investigation
and he says a lot of things that the
Democrats are gonna have a real tough
time putting him back in the box so the
first thing that he says is that Trump
is not crazy to worry about the leaks
inside his administration so Democrats
have been saying that Trump is just
using the leaks as a way to distract
from all the real issues with his
candidacy and with his and with his in
with his administration it's just not
true John Brennan says the leaks have to
be stopping remember this is an Obama
guy
and those two protocols are one is that
such intelligence classified
intelligence is not shared with visiting
foreign ministers or local ambassadors
it's shared through intelligence
channels because it needs to be handled
the right way and it means to make sure
that it is not exposed he didn't do that
if again if the press charges are
accurate secondly before sharing any
classified intelligence with foreign
partners it needs to go back to the
originating agency to make sure that the
language in it is not even just
providing a substance going to reveal
sources and methods and compromise the
future collection capability what I
would very concerned about though is the
subsequent releases of classic what
appears to be classified information
purporting to a point to the originator
of the information lays on partners
these continue to be very very damaging
leaks and I find them appalling and they
need to be tracked down
okay so there is there's bitten that
there is Brennan basically saying what
Democrats have been denying for a while
which is that these leaks are bad okay
it's not good that the leaks are coming
out he rips Trump for spilling
classified information that's Trump's
perogative obviously I don't think he
should have done it I think that he's
loose lips sink ships but by the same
token Trump is the President of the
United States that's not a crime it is a
crime to leak all of this intelligence
to the papers because remember we didn't
learn directly from Trump as the general
public we didn't learn that it was an
Israeli source in Isis from the general
front from Trump himself we learned that
from leaks of the conversation to the
general public that's sort of a problem
Brendan went even further he was asked
about contacts between the Trump
campaign and Russia and he said straight
out no I don't really have evidence of
collusion there may be contacts but no
evidence of collusion I encountered and
I'm aware of information intelligence
that revealed contacts and interactions
between Russian officials and US persons
involved in the Trump campaign that I
was concerned about because of known
Russian efforts to suborn the such
individuals and it raised questions in
my mind again whether or not the
Russians were able to gain the
cooperation of those individuals I don't
know whether or not such collusion
that's your terms such collusion existed
I don't know but I know that there was a
sufficient basis of information and
intelligence that required further
investigation by the bureau to determine
whether or not US persons were actively
conspiring colluding with Russian so
buried in that statement is he doesn't
know right he doesn't know that there
was collusion he says there are
connections between the Trump campaign
in Russia we already know that we know
mana for was connected with Russia we
know Flynn was connected with Russia but
we're not learning anything new here
from Brennan all we're hearing is I was
suspicious but we never really uncovered
anything and then Brennan is asked was
there pressure from Trump at any point
to end the investigation and he says I'm
not aware of any pressure to end any
investigation from President Trump I
have any members of the IC shared with
you
their concerns that the president was
attempting to enlist the help of people
within the intelligence
to drop the Flint investigation no sir
are you aware of any efforts the
president has made to enlist the support
of inner intelligence community person L
to push back on a narrative involving
the collusion issue that mr. Rooney was
asking about I am unaware of it okay
again he keeps saying all of these
narratives that the left has been
pushing there's no evidence for them so
he says is there any evidence of Trump
pressuring and is what Schiff says and
Brennan says I haven't heard anything
about that so you have the New York
Times report last week that comes out
and says that all of these people were
pressured and no one yet has actually
come out and said that they were
pressure there's yet to be anybody who's
coming out formally and said their
pressure was had anonymous sourcing but
commis gonna testify he's gonna have to
answer a very simple question that is
that's gonna remain on the table here
and that is why didn't you quit if you
feel like you were so pressured why
didn't you just quit okay as somebody
who felt pressured at the an
organization called Breitbart news you
know with regard to to the the the love
for President Trump I quit when I
thought they were doing something
illegitimate I quit ivko me thought
something a legitimate was happening he
too should have quit so you know John
Brennan is basically exploding left
narratives he's but he's burying the the
lead right I mean he's he's burying all
of the language about how there's no
collusion in lots of language about how
they're suspicious smoke but bottom line
no collusion no evidence of tampering no
evidence of any of this stuff and yet
the left continues to go completely nuts
over it well we'll talk more about that
I also want to talk about the the budget
and president Trump's budget but before
we do you're gonna have to go over to
Daly wire.com and become a subscriber so
Daly wire comm $8 a month gets you a
subscription to Daly wire comm you can
part of the mailbag tomorrow watch the
rest of the show live hard Andrew
clavin's mailbag get all of your
questions answered being part of his
show live as well and if you get an
annual subscription right now
then get a free signed copy of a new
book coming out by me and my dad called
say it so it's all about the 2005
Chicago White Sox baseball championship
season and it's really more about
father-son relationships it's sort of a
diary that we kept all the way through
the 2005 season it's kind of a rough
year for both of us and it's it's I
think it's actually a pretty moving book
about fathers and sons in baseball and
you should you should check it out over
at daily wired.com when you become an
annual subscriber I will sign the book
for you will send it directly to your
home makes a great Father's Day gift by
the way so if you're going to give a
gift subscription now is the time your
dad will definitely appreciate it
mark levin endorses the book he says
it's great dana perino says it's great
jerry Kresnik from from espn.com says
it's terrific so i think it's a really
good sports book and a really good
parenting book and a good relationships
book so you can check it out say it so
when you get that annual subscription or
if you just want to listen a little bit
later then go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud and you can listen there we
are the largest conservative podcast in
the United States
you